[Music]
hey everybody its charlie we got new
Dragon Ball super movie to talk about if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos we got
new details about bro Lee Paris what's
going on where all these fights are
taking place and they just dropped a
whole bunch more promos character
posters and the animators have been
doing interviews talking about the movie
itself so let's break it down the
biggest new thing that everyone's
talking about now is that supposedly
Paris is wearing a special device on his
belt here that may be a version of the
original mind control device from the
old Broly movie there was a newer promo
that made it look like bro Lee was
fighting but wasn't really into it in
the way that you would expect him to be
like when you see him in the trailer
here he's gone into what they call full
power bro Lee mode like instead of
calling it legendary Super Saiyan form
in this moment here they're just calling
this full power bro Lee he doesn't seem
to be in complete control of himself so
a lot of people think that this is
actually paradis mind controlling him
and using him to take over the universe
the same way that he was trying to do in
the original bro Lee's story in the
original version of events bro Lee was
born with so much power and grew up so
angry and uncontrollable that paradis
was really afraid and he had the
mind-control device created just to keep
him from creating too much collateral
damage like if he couldn't protect
himself from his own sons power there
were gonna be big problems once he got
the device on him and found that it was
working he was able to keep bro lee
below his own power level so that he'd
never be able to challenge his father
then it turned into more of a galactic
takeover arc he found that if he could
control his power he could use him to
take over other planets the way they got
around that in the original movie is
that the mind-control device broke when
he went legendary super saiyan when he
met goku again for the first time in
forever he hated him as a child even
though the backstory was a little flimsy
like literally just seeing Goku again
powered him up to legendary Super Saiyan
broke the device so he became
uncontrollable again Toriyama has
changed his backstory for the movie a
little bit but the BIOS that they
released the new ones just say that bro
Lee has come to Planet Earth on a
mysterious mission they don't say what
that mission is but that just lets you
know that this arctic area where they're
fighting isn't some random
planet this is actually planet Earth
like in this promo image - it says earth
has Goku so it makes it sound like at
some point bro Lee will threaten the
safety of planet Earth but that might
not initially be the reason that brings
them to the planet so a lot of people
are wondering because this movie is
going to get into the origin Saiyans
the origin of the Frieza force and
freezes backstory in his relationship
with them this is gonna have something
to do with recontextualizing the
destruction of planet vegeta freezes
role in eliminating the original sands
and sort of this confluence of events
because they're all wearing their Frieza
force armor here so what makes it sound
like he's either been somewhere else or
in hibernation or in another universe
and that's the reason why Goku has never
met him before because the whole thing
is that Vegeta and Goku have no idea who
this is when he shows up at the end of
the Dragon Ball super tournament of
power series Frieza said that he had
returned to the Frieza for sorry I've
been gone now time to resume our job of
taking over the universe
me not some well not us a smashed-up
would you not be so maybe Frieza is the
reason why Broly in Paris and therefore
scum to earth maybe it's connected to
that Frieza post-credit scene but maybe
they maintained some of this Broly Paris
relationship whereby Paris has been
controlling Broly
maybe the necklace is the new version of
that mind control device and it's
somehow breaks when freezes trying to
use them to take over the planet because
the way the trailer is pitching Broly is
that they come in it seems relatively
organised Paris orders him to attack
then things go completely nuts and it's
this unwinnable fight that they both
have to power up because they can't do
it alone I don't think they've released
any footage of it yet because you mostly
just see Vegeta and Goku biting Broly
but they actually do go fusion to fight
him later but basically they're not
powerful enough as they are here so they
go fusion that's still not powerful
enough like they just go through all
their different transformations and it's
still not enough to take him down you
guys can let me know in the comments
though what do you think broglie's
secret mission is that brings him to
Planet Earth before things go completely
crazy with all these fights later in the
trailer the other thing I have not
spotted in any of the footage but I was
looking at the IMDB again it actually
has the voice actor that does Goku and
Goten credited as doing bar dogs so they
might actually be doing a Bartok
flashback when we got that comic-con
trailer a lot of people theorize that
that's what this shot is supposed to be
here but because the trailer is trying
to sell us on the backstory of broli
I think most of these flashback scenes
like all these sayings in their pods
here is meant to be part of broglie's
origin story but in the original movie
Goku was right here - growing up riff
Broly as a child so they could be
carrying some of that forward to the new
movie - so even if these are Broly
flashbacks they could also be Goku
flashbacks the animation director was
also talking about bringing back the
power poles so they released this promo
image and he just said that it was meant
to show that they were going back to the
original manga because it's meant to
mirror this pose where go Han is holding
it but the idea is is that with a lot of
this classic looking animation they're
taking things back to his roots so I
think a lot of people already kind of
got that when they released the first
teaser a couple months ago
[Music]
like oh we have all the Dragon Ball
super designs but now the movie is
trying to make it look much more like
the original Dragon Ball animation these
are some of the new character posters
they released to giving you an idea for
what the character models are gonna look
like so this is just Super Saiyan blue
Goku and Vegeta burly in his legendary
Super Saiyan form although like I said
they're just calling this full power
burly Bulma Goten trunks piccolo that
looks like he couldn't be bothered he
doesn't care about anything that's going
on here I love the look on his face then
gold form Frieza here's another new one
of Goku and Vegeta and Super Saiyan blue
form tag-teaming Broly who's just in
regular Super Saiyan form better look at
para gasps and that special
quote-unquote device on his belt well
let me know in the comments what do you
want them to do with the next new series
after this movie leave all your
Dragonball video requests in the
comments below a lot of you have asked
me to do videos for Dragon Ball super
episodes what'll probably happen with
that is I'll do Dragon Ball super movie
videos and then whatever like the next
big Dragon Ball series is that's when I
would probably start doing weekly
episode videos but click here to rewatch
the Dragon Ball super movie trailer and
click here for brand-new Avengers for
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]